my presentation today is going to be
autobiographical so sample size of one
don't take it too seriously so Who am I
I am a data scientist with nanotech
galaxies we do machine learning
algorithms to analyze radiological
imagery so matter we do we use machine
learning to predict diagnosis that would
have been done by radiologists if he was
looking at a at an x-ray for example so
quite complicated stuff now six months
ago I was a project manager for a
development company now one might think
how the hell did I get to become a data
scientist from a project manager now one
caveat is that I'm actually a
mathematician so that's helped a bit but
from the time I did my degree I spent
two years working in a completely
non-technical industry with people who
do not know how to format an Excel
spreadsheet let alone compile a machine
learning model so why did i hack why did
I decide to do it so quickly why did i
hack my career now I had a bit of a
falling out with the academia when I was
back at school I've always been called
the smart but lazy student I've always
done my assignments at the last moment
I've never been well have been some of
the teacher's pet but not all of them
definitely so when it got university it
got worse so I suddenly realized that
wait a minute I don't actually I'm not
in love with what I'm doing I'm not
particularly excited about half of the
subjects I'm falling asleep at 10 a.m.
even if I had 10 hours of sleep the
night before so even though I was a big
fan of maths and a big fan of science I
decided not to do a PhD when I graduated
I realized that I wasn't going to
survive it and as I'm seeing from a lot
of my friends doing their PhDs they're
just barely surviving it themself
so I decided to become a data scientist
about a year ago when I watched a TED
talk by Jeremy Howard the CEO of
analytic who are actually now our main
competitors at the moment and I was
really inspired I finally realized that
my long-standing interest in the
sciences and in the nearest in
neuroscience as well could be made into
a career which is a III research machine
learning but how do you actually do that
when I started researching into degrees
I realized that well it's going to take
me one year for a master's and three
years for a PhD if I get the funding or
if I get is accepted I quit my job
November last year if I were to go for a
master's degree it would have cost me
28,000 pounds as a non-eu student and I
would have and I would have started in
November this year
not not now even so I would have still
been in my job which I hated not knowing
what my future is suffering from
uncertainty and facing a large bill from
the university as well as the living
expenses so I decided not to do it I
quit my job and I saved some money and I
just devoted six months to learning to
teaching myself to become a data
scientist as quickly as possible why
would this even work as an approach now
because everybody knows that we've got
these universities everybody wants to go
and do a degree because that's what
people normally do well from practice
one might might suspect that in fact a
lot of social systems are hackable you
don't generally have to follow the rules
if you are if you actually become a bit
scientific and a bit of a statistician
you can take calculated risks and
calculated inconveniences that other
people decided not to
we're too afraid to take and actually
find a much faster route no why does our
society support higher education in
general the standard answer to that is
because while there's social pressure
because you're expected to do a degree
but that wasn't the case a hundred years
ago nobody graduated from school they
hunted like in the 19th century what you
had was people transitioning through
labor people transitioning through
family connections or a pure talent and
being noticed why do we now do our
degrees well one might say that while we
need a more structured approach we need
to actually and this is valid we need we
need primary education we need people we
need children to be guided into their
careers too and have some standardized
base from which to build upwards but an
economist called Robin Hanson also has
another idea specifically about
university and higher education it's not
about social pressure it's about social
signaling it's about prestige it's like
wearing a Prada bag or a little bit on
heels for girls so what you're actually
doing is by having a degree you are
telling the employers that well you've
been good enough to get into this
University
you've been it's like a label that is
easy to validate and is easily
noticeable so this is why the new
equilibrium is that this generally
people go into higher education now we
don't just try to transition into doing
things straight after school or even
after primary schools would have been
done even 50 years ago but the cost of
that is increasing so if you look at the
cost of education in the state between
1980 and 2014 it has skyrocketed
the average student is now facing an
insurmountable debt if they if their
family obviously isn't rich enough to
pay
them so this situation looks a bit like
the tulip trade in Amsterdam so the
markets got so much out of control we've
got a bubble here quite obviously and
because we've got a bubble clearly it's
not a very good idea to buy into that
there must be another way we do you
don't have you're not in an absolute
need of something but let's say what if
in fact education gives you some value
what if it's not just about social
signaling well there is some evidence
against that there was a two researchers
called Schmidt and hunter did a
meta-analysis of the best predictors of
success of an employee after interviews
as per employer now the best predictors
are obviously work sample test how well
have you seen them do their job do their
job
IQ because the higher the IQ the faster
person would generally learn employment
interviews but just the structured ones
the unstructured ones are far way down
the list so if you have a standardized
approach if you asked everybody the same
questions you can weed out the people
who are worse and pick out the people
who are better job experience number 14
the fact that you have 10 were 10 years
of work experience doesn't say much
about how good you're going to be at
your job even in your existing industry
and number 16 we've got years of
education
it explains 10% of the variance in job
performance so really if if you have
spent five years on after University on
PhDs and postdocs it really doesn't say
much about you in real terms so even if
you might get an easier time finding a
job you're not going to get an easier
time keeping a job and moreover it
doesn't guarantee that you're going to
find a good job or a job that you're
going to enjoy this is something that's
going to be controlled by other factors
like how intelligent your hope is
persistent you are how much have you
practice 10,000 hours anybody hover has
anybody read Malcolm Gladwell's outliers
there you go so it's not about it's not
about intelligence alone it's not about
practice alone but the two together make
a winning recipe and they do not depend
on where you went to uni obviously the
the two are correlated so if you've got
persistence and intelligence you will
you would have gotten to a better unit
but maybe you just lucked out or maybe
you work you gamed the school's
educational system which is very
different from actual industry and
that's allowed you to get good grades
and get into a good university but
writing an essay a week to a pre-defined
crazy a set of criteria isn't the same
as putting software into production at a
two weeks notice and you don't even know
what it's going to be yet so I really
get a betting on education isn't a very
good idea in general assuming you know
what you're doing though ouch so what
does it mean for me first of all as I've
already said I didn't want to pay 28 K
on a on tuition fees alone these are the
real figures by the way this is how much
masters and machine learning and
statistics cost at UCL and also a
similar degree at Imperial they all cost
about twenty eight thousand pounds and
they are all so few and far between if
you want to go for a boot camp
there is one ie private education which
is more practically oriented there are a
few but there is as far as I'm aware
there is only one decent course in
London and they take 20 people at a time
which is yes which is the general
assembly course if you've got if you've
got a PhD you might be able to go for
science to data science through the ASI
fellowship but they do require PhD so an
extra three years of work actually
because of the number of applicants who
already hold those degrees you will be
at this
advantage when employing those or when
applying for those when you only hold
the bachelors like I do now as I said
starting date the cost of education is
not just monetary at the moment there is
no way in within the UK educational
system to advance your degree to do it
faster you have to plow through the
three years if you're doing a bachelor's
you have to you can do a PhD faster you
can't do your masters faster so if you
actually want to minimize the cost and
pay lower tuition fees you're not
allowed to do that because the
admissions committee the exam committee
meets once a year and they don't care
that you want to get a job faster so you
you don't get the flexibility you're
your starting date so later and the
industry is developing now there is high
demand now for data scientists there may
not be in three years time there might
be a glut in three years time so purely
from economical perspective I the cost
of doing a degree is quite high and
obviously there's also the question of
getting funding for a PhD or getting a
good advisor for a PhD so not being
forced to write on a topic that you
don't don't care about and that maybe
two people will read and really doesn't
guarantee improved career prospects you
might get a job but you will be stuck in
it for ten years
if you can't demonstrate your ability by
other things by things other than your
degree so how do you actually go about
it first of all things not to do hope
that a university degree is the ticket
to rosy future have already seen that
it's not expected do it all on your own
so my people might assume that okay
since I decided not to go to university
I just became a lone wolf sat down with
a book and just read and read and read
and coded encoding encoded and there
Here I am now first of all when you're
starting you don't know what you don't
know you need feedback one thing that
defines good education and good
no outcomes is how much feedback you get
and how frequent it is students who
students who sit a test before they even
start reading the material and are
graded on it will then learn the
material better but as as being scored
by a subsequent test compared to those
who haven't had a test previously so
it's good to jump in at the deep end
it's good to understand what you do not
know it's good to go and do a hackathon
even if you're only a beginner because
then you will actually get glimpses of
what professionals are doing
universities did not tell you that
moreover they don't give you the
state-of-the-art techniques until you
get three years into your degree into a
PhD when you're expected to gradually
find it out on your own sitting in an
office not talking to people so don't
expect to do it on your own not just
from the perspective of understanding
things but also from the side of time
management when you're on your own is
very easy to procrastinate if you're
sitting reading a book you get your
favorite shows comes on you're going to
watch the show for two hours instead of
reading the book if you're seated
sitting and reading the book with a
friend less likely so if you are due to
present on that book to a group of 200
people the following team may be even
less likely so a good thing about not
doing things on your own is that you
have social pressure you've got social
responsibility to stick to your goals
and generally humans are very bad at
sticking to their goals when there
aren't they're the only ones watching
when there are the only ones assessing
themselves you need external input not
allow for a margin of error you don't
when you're starting aid a software
development project on a novel on a know
like developing a completely new product
how many of you have actually managed to
do it exactly on time
as initially defined how many did not
raise your hands there we go so do not
expect it to be the same when you're
doing self education it's a complex
project you don't want to when you make
a first estimate multiplied by three and
expect it to take this much this long
similarly when you're pitching to an
investor and they see you of your
financial your financial plan they they
divide it by three because people tend
to be very optimistic about how long
it's going to take them to do something
and how much they're going to
procrastinate or how late the whole
little rather don't burn your bridges if
you're jumping into a risky into a risky
project into a risky venture realize
that it's risky there is always certain
odds of you failing don't completely
burn your bridges don't completely kind
of tell your boss to go away and leave
you alone and you're never coming back
make sure to leave to stay friends and
to get avenues to be able to come back
into your old industry should you wish
so or should you need more time or
should you run out of money always have
a plan B because everything that you're
doing the fact that you're hacking
through things mean that you're taking a
riskier approach it's some more it's a
higher payoff but it's also a higher
risk and the more and the higher there
was usually the higher the risk so
you're are likely to fail and you will
fail repeatedly until you finally
succeed and when you finally get to
interviewing don't hope that the
employer can read your mind
so you've learned all of these things on
your own but that you don't have a
degree you need a way of still providing
this social signaling so that other
people know that you're competent now
I'm going to go through these points
what did I do
in the end first of all set a realistic
time frame I put aside a year - for this
project equivalent to a master's degree
I knew I was going to be most likely
able to do it for
but I had enough money to sustain myself
for a year and this way I knew I didn't
have to rush I knew I didn't have to
despair when I failed repeatedly until I
finally succeeded don't trust yourself
with sticking to deadlines I didn't sit
and read the book on my own I didn't go
into a Coursera course in hope that I
knew everything I signed up to as many
meetups as I could before I started my
own then I started my own now I'm
responsible for giving a presentation to
200 people looking expectantly at me and
it's kind of embarrassing if I don't
know what I'm talking about
so this give this gives me deadlines I
joined my classmates at UCL for a study
group on a statistics textbook which is
by the way the main text for the machine
learning masters at UCL so if you create
a structure around yourself then you're
able to replicate what University would
give you you create yourself deadlines
and more importantly you create costs
for missing those deadlines having a
cost is very important if you don't have
anyone around you who will you if you
don't have a group around you that's
will penalize you for not sticking to
your deadlines there are services that
allow you to make a bet where you you
pay the money if you don't stick to your
deadline they pay to a charity you hate
like Trump supporters so if you don't
learn data scientists science Trump will
win make a study plan so the first thing
I did was scope the scope the area of my
study figure out what are the latest
developments when did it all start turns
out it didn't start that long ago even
though the first neural network were
networks were developed quite a while
ago in the 60s the computing power has
only been sufficient in the past four
five years to do it and they on any kind
of large scale so I was like we're all
lucky there because the there is still a
lot of scope for growth this is similar
to what happened when the internet first
started
getting high speeds when people suddenly
realize that oh you can have internet on
your mobile what can you do with that
apps lots of apps so you need to scope
what you don't know and make a study
plan make don't stick to it too rigidly
because you will find out new things on
the way but at least you need to have an
idea of how much you're going to have to
cover and when the deadlines should be
finally prepare for uncertainty you
don't know that you're going to be
capable of learning everything in the
time you have planned for yourself some
things will naturally be difficult you
will Plateau sometimes sometimes it will
get stuck with code or sometimes you'll
get stuck with setting up your AWS
server or installing cafe on your laptop
whatever allow for these things there's
as with project management when as when
you're putting a new product a new piece
of software into production there's
always delays this is exactly the same
as a project manager
luckily I've suffered more than my fair
share of that even an even though it was
in another industry so I knew all too
well that I can't plan to do everything
exactly on time so allowed for twice as
much time as I was as I was expecting to
spend willpower self study requires
willpower and being organized well power
is a limited resource we are often told
that ok you just need to try harder well
yes you can try harder but for a limited
amount of time you can't just go and
sprint for three hours straight because
your body is going to run out of energy
your muscle is going to run out of
oxygen your it's gonna stop working your
body will refuse to keep on going and
doing this so your brain is exactly the
same you're not going to be able to
exercise with willpower to unlimited
lengths so you need to be able to
measure how much you have and how much
you can realistically
and perge exercising it don't expect to
sit down and study for eight hours a day
if you've quit your job because you want
studying is a much more intensive
exercise it's a much higher cognitive
load than sitting and doing a task you
used to do don't expect to be able to do
that allow for four hours do more if you
can external reinforcement and social
cost of default by the way social cost
of default is how they sold
micro-financing if when lenders tried to
lend to a sink try to implement micro
lending by lending to a single person
the defaults were skyrocketing there
were like 50 bits in the tens of
percents though 50 60 70 percent because
if the person didn't pay back the loan
nothing happened to them well they got
told off by the lender but who cares
however when they started lending to
groups of people
say six or seven people come together
and lend some money to do a social
enterprise or whatever the default rates
drop to 2% this is what you get with
corporate lending for nice large
corporations with millions of turnover
why because if one person defaults the
other six have to pay their debt now
once you've got a social cost of default
you're a lot less likely to try and
cheat to try and not pay back your debts
because there is a high cost of doing
that you will be humiliated by your
peers humiliation is a much higher it is
a much better deterrent than losing
money or even losing your job therefore
try to try to introduce as many
deterrence as possible to not sticking
to your goal and finally limit your
choices
humans are not good at dealing with
multiple choices especially when they're
allowed to change their mind they did a
study where they gave people a choice of
two images to post us to keep now some
of those people just chose a poster and
took it home the other
off shows a poster and a week later they
were allowed to change their mind and
swap the poster now when later on they
were questioned about how happy they
were with the choice those who are
allowed to change their mind were
significantly less happy than those who
are not so you will need to if you plan
to transition into a new industry you
will need to manage your mood you will
need to manage your state of mind
because if you get depressed if you get
dis encouraged you're less likely to
continue the happier you are with your
choice the more likely you are to have a
good mood and have the energy to study
therefore limit your choices don't give
your limits your uncertainty as much as
possible because you will have a lot
anyway so if you've decided to do
something commit to it do it for as far
as you for as long as you can until well
until you fail beyond reasonable doubts
then you can change your mind but don't
try to just move between different
strategies every single day or today I'm
learning one topic but maybe I should
learn another one so maybe I should
learn regression or maybe I should learn
XML or maybe I should learn Java
whatever so if you if you keep John if
you keep changing your mind it's not a
very good idea because it won't just
affect your productivity in terms of
learning progress it will also affect
your mood now time management techniques
Pomodoro who knows about Pomodoro
Technique okay so in sufficiently many
poor Medora technique means that you set
an alarm for 20 minutes and you commit
to working for those 20 minutes and then
you have a five-minute break or a 10
minute break that's where you know that
you're not facing hours and hours of
work because you will you have when you
have a long project the largest mental
deterrent is knowing that you don't know
when it's going to finish this way have
manageable chunks so you work for 20
minutes
then you have a break then you reset the
time I work with twenty more minutes
then you have a break again so one thing
that it does it prevents overworking
during the break you get to stretch you
get to stand up and you must obey by the
rules you can't overwork you can't work
for thirty minutes instead you must
stick by twenty minutes and when
especially when you have a tight
deadline this is a very efficient
technique because it forces you to do
something in those 20 minutes you can't
just sit down and look on Facebook
you're you have to be focused on your
work and it's only 20 minutes so it
doesn't hurt that much and you know that
you're going to have a nice break
afterwards space repetition don't try to
do hours like 10 hour chunks of work in
one go another example from education
when students learned for 3 hours
straight before an exam they performed
significantly worse than when they
learned for one over for one hour or one
hour over three days in fact to perform
similarly to the three hours they only
had to spend about less than two hours
time with spaced repetition when it was
over a few days so don't try to cram
it's not a very good idea if you manage
to space your practice over a few days
you will learn more and you will have to
spend less time doing it so why not do
it you'll get more time watching your TV
series afterwards anyway a value of
sleep when sleep-deprived you suffer
your working memory suffers your
concentration suffers you perform
significantly worse so it doesn't
actually pay to sleep less in order to
work more that doesn't help
you're more likely to your willpower
suffers the first this is one of the
main problems with investment banks
where people work 9:00 a.m. to 2:00 a.m.
hour hours because Dan Ariely
did some REIT is another researcher who
does quite interesting projects so he
looked at how likely are people to cheat
when they're sleep-deprived turns out
they're much more likely to cheat so if
you're looking at
Excel spreadsheet and in order to get to
bonus you only need to kind of tweak the
formula a little bit if you're if you're
sleep-deprived you're a lot more likely
to do that all of our bankers are
sleep-deprived so when you're studying
you must sleep enough it's all maintain
your mood and it will also allow you to
learn more efficiently
every little counts if you have a task
that you absolutely hate like the other
day I had to apply for a grant
I hate applying for grants I hate
filling out stupid questions I just
don't do it so in situations like that
twenty minutes might feel like too much
pain with Pomodoro so what you do you
reduce it to five minutes give yourself
a time limit do as much as you can in
five minutes then you can just drop the
task if you want to in this case you can
continue the point of this exercise is
to get started because once you've
actually started you feel that it
doesn't hurt so much so just may as well
continue it but first of all you
promised yourself five minutes and if it
still hurts you drop it afterwards you
may you may do another five minutes an
hour later but it doesn't feel like too
much pain and finally kill your
perfectionism you're not going to be
perfect I'm not perfect I started
learning data science half a year ago so
I'm not trying to compete with Andrea
however I'll know significantly more
than I did half a half a year ago I can
now teach people about it and this has
value so don't expect to become an
expert don't expect to be able to I
don't know humiliate others because then
you will be humiliated yourself so this
is not just about expectation this is
about modesty if you're modest if you're
not hoping to become a Superman with
your knowledge then you're likely to
have much more realistic expectations
and you're less likely to suffer from
perfectionism which will kill your
results perfectionism doesn't let you
get started because then you want to
achieve so much that the fear of failure
becomes too high
for you to even try now
the n-word not working everybody hates
networking but obviously since you're
not doing a degree you will need to
somehow find your connections you'll
need to somehow find a job and it's a
lot easier to find work through your
social connections than through
applications online because those
applications are frequently sorted by an
algorithm if you don't have and the
algorithms will have features such as
does this person have a degree does this
person have a PhD no discord you don't
want to be sifted out by a dumb machine
before you even get to talk to somebody
you don't want to cold-call people I've
tried that I worked at the recruitment
agency for two months it it's not
pleasant
and moreover most people get annoyed and
you tell and they tell you to go away in
harsher terms so what you do instead is
you make friends now to a lot of people
and we're nerds by the way so we're
introverts
so to a lot of people in the IT industry
networking is not pleasant because we've
always been taught that we need to go
and talk to people who don't really like
about something that they're interested
but we're not and then when you go into
a meeting like that into a networking
event it actually doesn't work because
your body language shows that you're not
interested in them that you're bored so
the conversation stalls and everybody
ends up kind of uncomfortable and kind
of unhappy and no results so the key to
this is actually be selective don't try
to please somebody try to find your
in-group a group of people who are
actually interested in the same things
as you do and go from there because you
don't have to start big obviously don't
go to comic-con and expect to find a job
there unless you are you know a
professional cosplayer but try to find
the group that belongs to that is
related to your
industry to data science in my case and
go there and make friends go to events
that you're genuinely interested in and
express your opinions raise your hand
pester the presenter because then you
are noticed the say you will start
meeting the same people over and over
and you'll make friends and you'll find
jobs and you'll get connections so this
is what I did I signed up to a lot of
meetups and went to every single one of
them and I was genuine I didn't like I
didn't like all of them but I liked I
liked enough to make connections and to
meet people and to find people who I
could learn from who are who are
practicing data scientists who I asked
about oh how do I build a booster tree I
didn't know that at the time but they
told me and all we have to do in this
case is ask because if you're in the
right group of people you get the right
kind of support and also you start
signaling belonging to the in-group by
the virtue of having seen you around
repeatedly people will assume that you
belong even if you don't share all of
the characteristics of that group even
if you're not a data scientist yet if
they've seen you at a hundred meters
they'll probably assume that you are so
they might come to you they need a new
employee if they're looking for somebody
you signal belonging this is the same
this is the same thing that your
education would signal otherwise and if
you don't have a degree you need to
signal a little by other means and also
create positive reinforcement so when
you talk to people you'll first of all
you'll figure out what works and what
doesn't you'll be able to ask questions
but also its pleasant its pleasant to
talk to people if you find the group
that you're interested in that the whole
point of the exercise is not to try and
be liked it's to find somebody who you
were who you will like because then
they'll like you in return reciprocity
people will tend to show affection to
those who show affection to them and in
any case this is still work you're not
going to like every single meeting
you're going to go to you still have to
get up and schedule them and go to them
regularly because
once in a while you will you will get to
one that where you will meet somebody
useful or somebody you will like
somebody who likes you
you get connections you get jobs but
don't expect every single one to work
perfectly just try to pick out the ones
that sound good to you and obviously
don't expect immediate results you need
to be seen multiple times you need to
develop your social skills until it
actually clicks all of a sudden and it
will not take one or two meetups it will
take maybe a month maybe two it depends
on what your existing level of skills is
by the way it also it's also a good idea
to do things like improvisation classes
anything that's a lot or dancing class
is anything that makes you humiliate
yourself or something that you think
will humiliate you in public is good
because then you're just sensitized to
it then you're happy to go and talk to
300 people then you're then you don't
care about somebody possibly not liking
you because otherwise if you are really
just really discouraged by every single
negative comment you might stop you
don't want that to happen you want to
desensitize yourself so resources what
did I actually do in technical terms and
I will post a lot there I have a very
long list which I will post on the slack
channel or possibly on the writer for
the on the presentation page on the PI
data website so first of all meetups PI
data L MLP my meat of science journal
Reading Club googled them there is a
machine learning there is a machine
learning meetup as well there's a look
go go and meet meetup calm and machine
learning into data science and you will
see that there are tens of those meetups
and they all meet quite regularly kind
you can very easily schedule one or two
every single week and go to them if you
don't find any that you like start when
you're
laughs even better why I started my
meet-up two months ago now there's just
under 800 members so I get to talk to a
lot of people I get to pester people who
visit my my meetup if I have any
questions Kegel and hackathons as soon
as you have the most basic knowledge
like for example I personally started
with Andrews Coursera course and machine
learning and I spent a month in that and
then the first thing I did afterwards
was do a Kegel competition
it was the potential competition and at
the point when I was starting it I
didn't know are at all so I had to learn
our I did it by looking at what other
people submitted in their code
understanding how it works debugging it
getting it to run in my computer then
when it got when the code got too slow
to run on my computer setting up a
Google cloud server mr. Google Cloud
virtual machine to run it for me it all
takes this is all learning this is all
things that you're gonna have to do as a
date as a practicing data scientist and
don't be discouraged if you don't know
if you don't know something if you don't
know google it copy somebody else's work
see how it works because textbooks will
not contain all of the advice package
machine learning packages don't have
very good documentation frequencies as
you may probably know looking at them
yourself so the best way to do something
is to practice if you can't find
something on Google then ask somebody
off the creator of the package ask on
Stack Exchange and people will answer
those questions quite happily this is
how you write your own textbook and this
is by far the best approach because it
it closely approximates what you do as a
working data scientist and this is why
you will get an advantage over people
who learned by via text books because
when I'm reading elements of statistical
learning it doesn't tell me how to
implement it how to put it into
production it tells me about the
statistics underlying the algorithms and
the author's tries to advertise the
particular algorithms they made came up
with themselves which doesn't
work very well but they like it however
when you try to translate that into a
career it doesn't really work it's a
reference text books are a reference
competitions is where the actual
learning happens hackathons go find
hackathons go to there are some that
deal specifically with cattle
competitions there are some that try to
deal with open source datasets for
example there was one at UCL where they
looked at NHS data and try to find
correlations within its modeling it etc
so try to find as many practical events
as you can and go to them because you
will make lots of mistakes at first you
will be extremely slow it will be
frustrating but you will be learning and
you will have to do that anyway should
you find work
Coursera there's plenty of free
resources so Coursera has the Stanford
course by and ruing it has a few others
related to machine learning look at
reviews look at what the course content
is pick the ones that you feel are most
useful for you Udacity Udacity has a
course intensive flow which has been
recently published by in cooperation
with Google so use those resources
they're there for you and they're free
know your stats data science is based on
statistics the reason why I managed to
transition into data science so quickly
is because it didn't take me that much
time to learn the basic stats but then I
didn't remember them at the time I
started my my city the last time I did
statistics was four years before then
when it was in my year two and we had a
lecturer who gave us notes and we just
filled out the blanks with I didn't even
show up to half of the lecture so I
didn't remember it I didn't know what
gamma function is but moreover you will
not need most of the university
statistics because at the moment what's
taught at university is even at a math
degree level is frequentist statistics
and what you need for data science is
Bayesian statistics you need updating
you need to update your expectations as
you as you see new evidence and this is
not covered by a lot of university
courses so books that I have looked at
was elements of statistical learning
it's a it's a book by Stanford
professors an introduction to
statistical learning with applications
whether I think by the same guys a book
on statistics by James which I don't
remember the title of but it's very
easily go global I'll post it on the
slack or on the website later on and
finally pass to people if you're lost
then find somebody to ask this is why
you need the networking by the way so if
you go if you're working on a project
then you go to a meet-up find somebody
who might know something ask them for
their advice they'll point you somewhere
not necessarily in the right direction
but it will move you off the offer dead
spot and this is all you need sometimes
and that's where you learn a lot faster
than by googling the wrong their own
queries a lot of the time and finally
read the white papers so the blogs do
not contain state of the art
competitions do not contain state of the
art if you want to really understand
where you want to get to even if you
don't get those papers at first go to
the top companies go to deep mind read
their white papers water what are they
doing go to Google Facebook look at what
they're publishing on data science and
machine learning look at the top people
in your field find out what they're
doing so that you know where where you
need to get to and also read those
papers repeatedly first time you read
them you may not understand them to two
weeks down the line once you've
practiced a little bit you may
understand most of the paper third time
you understand all of it and this is
again how you learn finally don't get
started this might sound like
controversial advice but when you're
embarking on a large on a complex
project don't just jump in don't burn
your bridges immediately plan first if
you're a project manager who has to I
don't know build an Eiffel Tower
are they going to decide okay we're
starting tomorrow I don't know where I'm
gonna get the steel from I don't know
where I'm gonna get the builders from
where I'm gonna get the machinery from
I'm gonna start tomorrow and I'll I know
the budget already I haven't asked
anyone don't do that so it took me about
a year of planning before actually well
slightly less than a year but about nine
months of planning before I actually
left my job
and I felt I was ready to embark on this
so make sure you know what where you're
actually aiming this is the key that
allows you to get there fast because
then you have the exact metrics by which
to assess your learning the same as you
would assess a learning algorithm you
need to have a loss function you need to
have a cost function how do you know
because if you don't know where you're
going you don't know how far you've gone
either and yes you need the right
questions where are you going so
question time
[Applause]